I want to give you guys 15 seconds to
explain the premise of this movie you
pick who goes first go I'm timing you
now one two three go bodega lassie
played back to mama soon returns
triumphantly and is the sort of the
center of mystery that revolves around
we have facility and normal keeping safe
what Jay King said I add in a lot of
them owed lots of Tears lots of laughs
and more tears 13 14 15 okay we can't do
it come on man imagined that going
better if it was scripted he's saying
thanks ghosts not necessarily goes let's
probably ghosts you really want to help
just grown men that you are can you I
don't want to burn another second let's
keep going Maggie talk to me why you
think this series has developed such a
fantastic fan cult following and I mean
cults in the best sense of the word
everyone loves it the fans want more
talking about that a little bit you know
I think honestly I don't know I I think
from the very beginning we we all
clicked so fast and we were having such
a good time and work was so fun
I feel the one thing we all hope for I'm
great for was that that transferred and
that people could feel that and see that
when we were working together and so and
I think that is hopefully what has
happened plus I think you know we we
love and really appreciate those psychos
so much and they have they have at
they're like a part of the team so I
think over time you know the mourner
actually we had with them as well we we
would hear feedback from them
they're the reason we're making these
movies so I think it became like a real
like holistic kind of thing so I I think
that's part of why of why why the cult
still is still there or or we'll call
them the psychos yeah
what's wrong with you two check it out
what is that that is a gift for you
meet Morrissey the rescue dog here to
rescue you from your own handsomeness
James we loved seeing your million
little things co-star Alice and Miller
pop up but dule we've got to talk about
the West Wing reunion with Richard
Schiff how do you how do you recruit him
for this it's pretty simple I mean wrote
a hit me up and said you think Richard
Schiff would want to play a role in this
in our show
I gave me a shout he was just finishing
up the good doctor so he was right in
that game oh yeah he did so he said
Dixon said I think dick snip would
wanted so I called him up and said hey
dick hey dick [ __ ] you uh I said you
wanna do me a solid
when come play a player role here on
cycling will be two and he said yes
right away you know I wish [ __ ]
family we've been we've been family
since the West Wing years and during the
psychics he would be an event cooler
working all the time so he ready new
road day he knew Maggie he knew Tim and
he he was down to be a project to come
another good song you know cuz
oftentimes it doesn't even get a chance
to play a lot of funny roles he's known
as being so serious so serious but
Richard is a is a very funny dude so it
nice to have you come up in you know
play around with this that's beautiful
and we're happy to see it we're also
hoping to get our West Wing reboot one
of these days James we have another
season a million little things to shoot
in Canada we hear production is is
resuming or planning on resuming well
one of those discussions been like how
they're gonna keep the cast and crew
safe other than you know what sag is
kind of rolled out just as curious as
you are man we haven't heard anything
definitive but we know that a lot of
discussions are happening unions unions
so you know we're gearing up we know
that you know they want us to get back
up there when they call we shall we
shall answer the call but yeah I'm
really I don't know what it's gonna look
like I don't know what seems gonna look
like I wanna be how long it's gonna take
the shooting episode I would suspect
certainly longer than
it passed so I think the hope is that
over the course of the next nine months
we'll be able to shoot an episode
[Music]